Почнемо з початку.
Деревина повинна висушитися!
Це — не деревина. Це — дрова.
Але тут є й деревина.
Ось це я поставив сушиться на довгий тривалий час.
Це — клен, бачите.
А це все дрова.
Але між них, між дровами я ставлю деревину.
Я, випадково, розбирав хату одну і знайшов...
Подивіться як густо йдуть тут волокна.
Я на пружини його використовую і на душки.
Душки — це такі маленькі кілочки,
які вставляються між деками.
Оце... У мене в запасі його дуже мало.
Ялини.
Їй уже близько 100 років.
100-ньої давнини... Із хати виколупав.
Це — рідкість дуже велика.
Оце матеріал...
Це — ялина
[показує на верхню деку скрипки].
Верхня дека.
Це — клен
[показує на нижню деку скрипки].
Це — також клен, інший вид.
Це — груша, самих...
Це під чорне дерево...
Це наше місцеве чорне дерево — груша.
Лишень її дуже довго потрібно сушити і в’ялити.
Бо вона має здатність таку — коробитися.
Якщо недосушена, то коробиться.
А так...
Мінімум до 10 років слід сушити грушу,
щоб не покоробилась, розумієте?
У мене така груша є.
Ось бачите, скільки запасів в мене?
Коли ще я вчився в школі-інтернат у Будівці.
Там був панський маєток, шикарний.
Пана Сабанського.
І побачив скрипку розламану,
розбиту, що лежала на шафі.
Почав я її…
Правда струни були...
Почав я її наструнчувати і так, і так.
І пробував зі смичком — не звучить,
звуку не міг добути.
Вибір був або...
Або за рахунок внутрішніх потенцій,
знань, умінь, навичок роботи з деревиною,
які накопичуються роками
і, врешті-решт, переходить кількість оця
дотиків з деревиною і з предметом самим,
перетворювати це все в якість, в скрипку.
Або вчитися в майстра.
У майстра мені не вдалося вчитися.
Я, можливо, реалізував би мрію раніше.
А коли я подивився...
Переломний момент був на сміттєзвалищі,
коли я побачив скрипку.
Я подився отак: «Боже мій!»
«Ну що ж тут такого складного!»
«Я можу краще зробити навіть».
І зробив!
Я першу скрипку зробив два роки тому. Оцю.
Я завершував університет,
біологічний факультет, у Вінниці.
Була, звісно, у мене перспектива
поступити в аспірантуру.
Але тоді часи такі були...
А в мене характер не такий,
щоб вчитися в аспірантурі.
І в 90-х роках я зв’язався із
Хельсінкською групою, так?
З Левком Лук’яненком.
Потім партія була, потім розкол був з рухом.
Я на з’їздах був, все це переживав дуже боляче.
У мене були плани.
Мрії дитячі потрібно було здійснювати.
Пожити!
Так як я хотів.
Все самому довелося починати.
Найперша моя скрипка і заграла.
Я не знаю як це так виходить.
Але таке буває в житті.
Можливо, у попередньому житті
я вже займався цією справою.
Почав вивчати ще працюючи сільським головою.
Почав збирати матеріал.
Спочатку поцікавився, з якого матеріалу роблять.
Посидів в бібліотеці.
Передивився багато відеофільмів,
що в інтернеті викладені.
Найскладніше — підбір деків.
І вистругування їх так, щоб...
І фарбування.
І товщина дек.
І механічні властивості деревини.
Щоб все було гармонічно поєднано.
І розміри, відповідно, великого овалу і малого овалу.
Вони повинні звучати з різницею, як мінімум, терція.
Бо ті звуки, інтервали, звучать
неблагородно, як то кажуть.
А от кварта, квінта звучать благородно.